you
[Music]
food delivery has swelled to more than
ten billion dollar a year industry in
America and it's partly due to ordering
apps such as doordash GrubHub ubereats
and many others
this year for the first time restaurants
are projected to make more money from
food consumed outside their doors than
inside but behind the seemingly
overnight success of these apps is a
more than two decade ever to change the
way we get food
brook silva-braga is here with the
origin story Brook good morning good
morning guys these apps facilitate
deliveries from high-end venues to chain
restaurants like McDonald's down to your
local diner grub hub which helped launch
the industry now says it processes five
hundred thousand orders every day a
remarkable leap from its very modest to
start how many people do you now have in
this building we have probably a
thousand like eight floors for GrubHub
founder Matt Maloney
the road to success started with long
walks through the streets of Chicago
just like this restaurant Lotus Bomi
would come up and I go in and get the
menu and make okay go for it yeah in a
way this is what transformed the
restaurant industry Matt and his friends
grabbing menus generally it's the paper
ones not these nice laminated ones but I
take this and I'd stick it in my pocket
and run to the next one so you get all
the menus and then you're just sitting
in front of a computer creating a list
that we now take for granted yeah like a
whole new database of all the
restaurants as no one had aggregated
before grubhub.com at least a version of
it for part of Chicago went live way
back in 2004 the same year Facebook
launched it was like a repository for
menus that delivered to you that was
dynamic based on where you were GrubHub
wasn't delivering the food that was up
to the restaurants what they did was gin
up business by making it easy for diners
to order we were able to go to
restaurants and say for every dollar of
your food did I sell I'm gonna keep 10
cents but I think for online food
delivery actually dates back to 1999
when a company called seamless web began
delivering to law firms in New York they
eventually merged with GrubHub but
concept caught on pretty slowly as
Maloney himself conceded as recently as
2012 I mean if you walk down the street
here and said what's GrubHub like no one
no one would know yeah so it was a lot
harder pitch back then paddy Barrett was
hired to help sell restaurants on the
idea in 2011 sure it's exciting first
job you call your parents yeah you say
I'm working for this thing called
GrubHub and they say what they thought I
said Groupon so it's my first selling
experience I guess you think you're
selling your parents don't worry yeah
it's really simple so yeah but then
something changed you pick the menu
items that you want to order from maybe
it was the rise of the smartphone Renae
and an online ordering mushroom spicy
lamb meatball sandwich by 2014 GrubHub
had gone public today it's worth four
and a half billion dollars but it's
battling for business with new
competitors with big investors behind
them including uber eats post mates and
biggest of them all door - which is
valued at more than twelve billion
dollars yeah these things yes all
different all different apps white maze
in Brooklyn New York uses almost all the
apps to sell their Venezuelan arepas and
rice bowls Kathy Valera bought the
restaurant in 2018 you seemed pretty
busy people walking in why even bother
being on these apps because when I get
the restaurant like a year and a half
ago it wasn't done busy the restaurant
was making barely a hundred dollars a
day then she signed up with GrubHub and
Thursday it was made $300 secondly it
was a far
Thursday like five hundreds on oh my god
you know today is $3,000 so that's why
I'm like in love with all the type of
apps that we have but all those orders
are not free what do you pay for grab
them 20% a lot of restaurants complain
that commission is too high
they provide the food you make the match
is that worth 20% of what I pay for a
meal so we don't actually define our
prices we define a minimum in most
places is 10% to receive orders on crop
hub so they're choosing to pay that is
your point
the restaurants competition are choosing
to bid up that average price for typical
exposure the best exposure on the app
costs more up to 30% for some
restaurants and the importance of that
exposure has become evident even to
places like the family corner diner in
queens new york a neighborhood
institution for more than 30 years
nobody wants to owner george calves
Adeus says GrubHub deliveries now make
up about 20% of his business do you feel
like you need to do this is this a good
to have or a must have I think in the
restaurant business it's a must have
it's difficult to not deal with these
people with this type of business
because you need it that's in part
because GrubHub is so good at something
called search engine optimization
they're just Google family corner
Astoria when you search for family
corner the top results take you to grub
hub or seamless --is page for the
restaurant is this your phone number
that they're showing no and if you call
the number on that page press 1 to place
an order it gets to George evidence only
after it's routed through grub hub and
we hear the phone ringing what not
everyone realizes is that grub hub
charges for that too thank you
if they call up place in order then you
get hit with a fee right but if I call
the seamless number comes directly to me
is still a phone call most restaurants
are paying a fee for these balls not
that I know of after looking at his
statement George told us he is paying
those fees and he will stick with grub
hub picking up these menus in a way
meloni walking
to all those restaurants helped usher in
a world where people are less likely to
walk into restaurants they're not
walking down the street they're not
going to the phone book and looking for
their local restaurants they're going on
a digital platform to find out who
delivers for them the relationship
between humans and their local
restaurants are changing and has been
changing really ever since we started
this business one interesting direction
this could be heading is what's called
cloud kitchens these are basically
restaurants that only deliver there's
not even a storefront to walk into
Travis kalanick the founder of uber is
one of the big investors in this site
yeah my son uses this app or all three
of those apps like nobody's business
it just doesn't seem fair though that
they get that much out of the business
through the cut and it's not just with
restaurants right now we're seeing
pushback to something called class pass
which does this for fitness studios when
an app comes in and gets involved in
real-world business it can change a
whole business model I know when we did
a story on some of these apps and
restaurants scaling some of their menus
for it the one thing they did say is
they don't have to pay benefits to a
delivery driver they don't have to worry
about some of the other things that go
with it so when you look at that cut
while it's very high because you're
getting it from every restaurant for
some businesses there's that reason that
they want to also thanks Brooke